oh my god
oh my god tommy's been bad
[Music]
what are you waiting for you know what
[Music]
forgive me tommy
[Music]
or some raccoon
[Music]
a zombie's a raccoon right
no it's just zombies
oh you just killed tommy
all right listen up sheriff's
department's close by we'll be safe
there okay
stay close i'll get you out of here
they didn't get us okay we're still
alive
all right keep it together yeah okay we
got to make it to the sheriff station
oh my god
[Music]
we got to go through them just stay
together keep moving
and don't get bit go
hey are you getting this yeah what is up
all right let's go
this is crazy
[Music]
what
[Music]
ain't um some these are some racist
[ __ ] zombies why would you even
lock the door i mean the window's broken
and
oh oh hell no
no no no
oh um oh what is that they seriously
wouldn't let her eat us
hey guys isn't this great
these racist zombies are leaving us
alone come on we're having a party
the beer is here
[Applause]
hey man this is your first time no man i
i've been doing a zombie extra work on
this show since
day one first season man my first time
was your first time on this show my
first time being
extra at all ever kind of nervous
oh wow okay man hey man i'm sorry about
you you'll be all right man it's okay
man
it's not that hard man you'll be all
right i'm me personally dude i'm looking
for that lunge bump though
what's what's a lunge bomb oh that's uh
like if you
um you get featured if you lunge at
somebody and then you get a bump in your
pay
and if you're really lucky man they blow
your head off that's straight bank right
there
that's right assistant director gather
round jerry hey jerry i had a thought
man about the first scene that y'all not
now stan oh steve it's steve
okay okay i'm gonna need somebody to
lunge at the fence ah
you think you can handle it yeah uh
yeah it's his first dado he's kinda
nervous man he's kind of nervous this is
his first date okay
so the director's gonna yell action
mac's gonna come by and then you're just
gonna lunge into the fence like
you you want me to say grah oh say
whatever it's crazy
okay all right cool man hey you know hey
that's cool hey you know i got a lot
more experience man you can just use me
i've been here
day one first season so and okay cool
all right that's fine you're gonna go
with him all right good for you man good
for you
guys no don't do you don't have to say
god do whatever hell you want to do man
that's the lunch box that is the lunge
bump man you got it
you got it on your first day ever
being an extra ever you got it man good
for you
and action
what the hell was that cut oh man i
would be more than happy to fill in man
i'd be
more than happy to step in mac just
remember when you're coming through the
factory
that hey like your mind is still in the
car i mean you all got to pick people
based on qualifications man you can't
just be picking random a good note
the note but maybe what i was doing sort
of superseded that
agreed yeah we were just discussing that
absolutely it supersedes it yeah but uh
let's do one that just
seeds it okay just same level we're
going again straight away okay right
away okay
reset okay he's not doing a good job at
it you're doing great though man
opportunity knocks gonna answer the door
man
action
[Music]
i'll be more than happy to step in at
any time you want me to
i'll be more than happy to do it just a
certain sense of urgency is all we're
looking for
clock's ticking you've got survivors to
find right can't tell you off at
something real second
this dude right here is not doing what a
zombie does this dude was literally on
our last take
waving his hand up in the air like this
jerry making beaker sounds he sound like
beaker from the muppets y'all thank you
that's great just a ticking clock on
this is all we're looking for because
there are survivors that's what we're
after okay
i found the ambivalence in there the
ambivalence is art it's gorgeous and we
love it but there are zombies so if we
could just pick up the pace just a hair
that'd be great well straight away
please right away
jerry but we're not doing night of the
living muppets are we we're not cause
the beaker is not a zombie do you have
any notes
yeah don't be a beaker quiet please
action
i'm gonna eat your brains zombie god
no he actually just said the word zombie
come on man you ever hear a zombie say
the word zombie before no you haven't i
don't think so
you know what get rid of this guy thank
you that's what i'm talking about
i'm sorry dog but you're terrible at
this man do your thing hey man no he
talking about him
no he's talking about him because he
said zombie thank you steve no you want
me to leave
hey man i've been up here staggering
around here for three and a half years
and i've been startling extras left and
right when do i get the start of the
lead huh one more for safety straight
away you're ready
action
hey what do we do if we have to go to
the bathroom
we like it i love it genius moving on
thank god